well let's return to that story of the
health secretary matt hancock
uh you remember he's been pictured
embracing a an aid and breaking those
social distancing rules uh of the time
that was back in
early may uh we're going to go over to
mark kleinman now who's
got some breaking news on this and it
involves mark is on the phone
with us mark it involves gina carlo
d'angelo's brother in a string of nhs
contracts doesn't it yes that's right
what i can reveal today is that a
relative
in fact the brother of the white hall
director alleged to have had an
extramarital affair with mr hancock is
an executive at a private healthcare
company which has won
a string of nhs contracts now roberto
colo d'angelo
who i understand is uh jean nicola
d'angelo's brother
is the executive director of strategy
and innovation at partnering health
limited or phl
group which specializes in the provision
of urgent
and primary care services to nhs
patients now
there's no suggestion that phl group or
mr collard angelo
has acted improperly in the procurement
of government contracts
uh phl is declining to comment so far on
further details of those contracts while
the department of health and social care
has been approached for comment
nevertheless this disclosure will risk
deepening the crisis engulfing mr henkel
today
he's already been left weakened of
course after allegations about his
competence and tackling
the kobe 19 pandemic that have been made
in recent weeks by
dominic cummings boris johnson's former
top advisor
as we know mr hancock said earlier today
that he had let people down and was very
sorry
with the prime minister saying he
considered the matter closed but
it may be the case that the disclosure
of mr color d'angelo's
company's relationship with the nhs does
make it more difficult for
the health sector and in fact the
government to shut this story down